you're recording
yeah yeah ladies hello I have a quick
question would you like to participate
in our video nothing all right all right
cool ladies have some quick questions
you want to participate in our video no
thank you okay
yo brother do you want to participate in
the video
state
[Laughter]
do not touch me while I include yeah
yo I have some questions you guys don't
participate in the video no
cool okay
do you want to participate in a video
we're asking some cool thought-provoking
questions oh gosh all right cool cool
all right let's come over here let's
come over here let's go we'll do this
way we'll face it yeah yeah
all right what's up what's your name
Jason Jason I'm Atlas good to meet you
nice to meet you awesome
Jason our first question is do we all
come from the same source
oh yes
now
does that mean we are all one
all right Jason next question does that
mean our Consciousness our awareness is
shared
yes
interesting and will you elaborate a
little bit on how you've come to the
realizations that we come from the same
source that we are one and that our
Consciousness is just shared
um I think it goes back to a belief and
a higher power greater than myself
yeah
I think we're all spiritual creatures
and we all share energy
yeah yeah so I think we are all
breathing the same breath yes
yes yes so
another way to play with this is to ask
you how many different ways are there to
paint a blank canvas
how many different ways are there to
organize musical notes into songs
vibrate vocal cords to make languages
how many different ways are there to
put food together into recipes
made this reality just be one expression
of infinite possibility
all right I appreciate it thanks for
letting me be a part of your life and
thanks for being a part of my life
it's that simple right yeah
one appearance out of an infinite
possibility
Beautiful Jason thank you you're very
welcome so nice that was so nice you're
Rock bro thank you thank you thanks for
joining us yeah cool cool you too
yeah yeah it's hella trippy huh
yeah man this is a good start yeah it's
a good start yeah nice
oh
yo do you guys aren't participating the
video answer some stop revoking
questions it's super fun yeah
it's questions like that there's
questions like this shirt all right cool
cool let me uh let me come here kind of
like the Middle East area all right so
so my my name is atlas what are your
names Char Char cool Jamal Jamal Krista
Krista charge Mo Christa all right so
our first question is what do you think
is the nature of reality what is the
point of reality
age of reality
to live every moment as much as you can
amen amen the nature of reality
to a really big distraction to
beat your mind off of what's really
going on with being human with like The
Human Experience like distraction from
The Human Experience basically
okay
I think it's whatever you want it to be
[Music]
what is the role of consciousness
to guide you to making choices in life
[Music]
mm-hmm
okay
it makes me nervous
[Music]
do we all come from the same Source
what do you mean by Source what do you
mean by Source
I mean I fell for my mom so where does
your mom come from
um I mean I'm a chemist leader so I
think we're just all particles
provide together
whatever we are
full one yeah I think we all would when
you die you know you become the particle
again and somebody else
do we share our source
we all share our same Source I believe
so yes
okay
and then
would that then mean that our
Consciousness is also shared if we share
our same source
yeah I think I think
sometimes
[Music]
so could it could it be then that the
same observation or the same witnessing
is happening from all of our
perspectives at the same time right I
would say yes but that kind of ties back
to the first question of what is reality
because you know your reality might be
different my reality
[Music]
they were just all in public
small pieces of that puzzle so what you
see what I see it's kind of all add up
to a picture
I think we're pissed off
yeah
why is it not more simple than you know
it can be but it's hot
[Music]
okay last questions okay how many
different ways can we paint a blank
canvas
stuff
I mean how many different colors do you
have what's the math question right
there
[Music]
as Limitless possibilities
everyone is different could we say that
our nature is Limitless possibilities
um human nature is that what you mean
our nature in the most macro level
possible
is our nature Limitless possibilities
[Music]
us
there are a lot of possibilities
how would painting the blank canvas get
limited
[Music]
let's say they're an endless amount of
colors then why would it be limited
um
is it possible to run out of ideas
maybe for you not for me
right here that's not limited this is
constantly moving endlessly different
colors endlessly that might be your
nature
[Music]
shut up
cool and last question is what do you
think is most beautiful
[Music]
human connection
specific aspect that you really like a
lot I think that we can relate to each
other more so than you think
it was beautiful nature
we're all part of it
amen thank you guys so much that was
dope thank you thank you thank you thank
you there you go yeah yeah yeah for sure
if you guys want to check out I'll share
with you go to YouTube
yeah so my name's Atlas what's your name
uh Ryan good to meet you Ryan thank you
for are you the king of Atlantis or you
know yeah he knows he knows I'm a
Castilian so nice nice
Ryan thanks for stopping and I answered
a couple home questions
first question is what do you think is
the nature of reality what is the point
of reality
I mean reality is perspective you know I
mean believe me yeah if you're looking
for general answers you're talking to
the wrong guy on this because this is
what I'm out here searching for you now
so I mean
uh but you know it's your reality is
what you make of it you know and uh
it's as simple as that you know I mean
if you want you know things can be I
mean I got my wallet stolen on the bus
the other day you know so I'm kind of
stuck out here for the time being but if
you got to be stuck somewhere you know
we're better than here like
mm-hmm so
will you elaborate a bit on the answer
of perspective reality being so deeply
rooted in perspective perception
well I'm pretty sure the Roman Catholic
Church wrote my family out of History
you know has been hunting us down for
the last 2400 years you know but
you know that's not the perspective
anybody else is going to have on it but
um you know it's all interconnected you
know science uh if I get spiritual if I
don't call it religious you know that's
you know you're perverting Faith at that
point you know for some for your own
personal gain and uh
I it you know I mean
I love the generaless of it man you know
I if you want to be a little more
specific I might be able to you know
help uh dial you in you know
do we all come from the same source
I don't believe so
the library first uh
I believe they're what was here before
you know and then you know what
it's hard just talking about with you
know but I you know like I said I've
been doing a lot of research here over
the last three months since I took this
test and uh you know I know who my
parents are and I'm trying to figure out
how my DNA traces back
and I come from the ancestry DNA 11
different regions you know with my mom
being full-blooded Scottish
and the rest of it I am about a percent
each Scandinavian uh the rest of it
comes right out of the heart of the
Niger Riverdale to Mali uh Nigeria you
know and
you know but there's nothing in between
so how does you know how do you get from
there to Scandinavia you know and
uh so go back in the lineage far enough
we all come from the same Source
you know I can't I can't say that for
sure and I don't want to you know fair
but uh
what would it be that the perspective
the perception that we were talking
about earlier could that be shared could
that witnessing or the Observer that's
here in these units could it be shared
absolutely you know I think I mean just
the fact you know you're standing here
doing this you know and
I mean I don't know what you know your
end goal or your end game and this is
you know but it doesn't seem to be for
any you know malicious intent or you
know it's
you know I believe
that understanding is the highest form
of love you know and
you know I grew up in the church so you
know that word's thrown around very
loosely
but
you know what is are you willing to put
the work in you know or you know it's
just when the time comes to say it in
front of the camera you know are you
willing to you know
damn but when it comes time for the
rubber to meet the road you know you're
nowhere to be found I mean that's
you know I I yeah I don't know it's uh
it is what it is I mean it's that's
right that's right but if you don't mind
me asking you guys what are you you know
what is it I mean like obviously you
know you're just out here asking
questions and you know I'm a big fan of
asking questions I kind of like to be
the one to ask because I got a lot of
tough questions I think I need answered
you know but what are you guys uh here
for yeah we'd be happy to feel your
questions
well we came out here to ask people to
offer vocal questions to capture solid
answers stitch them together into a
project called infinivlog okay and then
disseminate that across our channels
shift so and what you know I mean you
have social channels which I mean you
know that's what life is about being
social what is your end goal in this you
know what do you I mean obviously
understanding it seems like you know
something you're seeking but have you
heard this song by NWA Express yourself
you know it's been a while you know so I
I am familiar yeah yeah but yeah that's
that's what we're doing okay
um
yeah that's uh kind of threw me for a
loop there you know but I can dig it um
it is the entire creation is one
expression how many different ways can
you paint a blank canvas
[Music]
infinitely you know I mean it's uh you
could leave a blank you know and it's up
to the people to determine you know
what's you know you could take a blank
canvas and paint it white and you know I
mean does anybody can know the
difference or
made that
then be what this is is one way to paint
that blank canvas
it absolutely can be you know it's and
like I said it's come down to your
perspective you know I mean you're out
here doing you know this and
I mean
what's the best question that you have
for us
oh my all mine are science related
Fair up
you know people want to know how they
built the pyramids you know
do you know who John Herrera is
sure so
according to the people you know he's uh
architect you know I
know you guys got your phone here but so
as far talking about my lineage this is
as far back as I could trace it
and so you have a deep interest in
anthropology and Archeology how we got
to where we're at today is that right
exactly you know and I mean more so how
I got because I was adopted out you know
my you know my birth mother you know I
couldn't you know handle responsibility
she made the right choice but
and I don't want to put anything but you
know I feel like the people who took
responsibility for me could have done a
better job in helping me find myself you
know instead of me being 34 you know
out here wandering around you know and
but so this is what I found looking here
and
maybe that's the point of your adventure
I you know I mean I believe every you
know I'm a United fan Excuse me yes but
uh I'm a United fan like we just got a
big win against city today you know we
played it the right way and it's I
believe it's in how you do things you
know it's
so
are you familiar with the Alcazar of
Segovia
no you can show Mariah also yes here we
go there's uh
ah okay tell me what he's looking at on
that piece of paper there
yeah you can gun blow it up I'm not you
know I'm not one of those people like
just don't swipe too far left or
anything you know I am human
would you call it a Stargate maybe oh
that's a good way to put it yeah a
Gateway Stargate yeah just like the show
like I mean and so people ask how they
build the pyramids you know and let me
show you the Alcazar here yeah please
uh that that little star gate right
there I mean this like I said this was a
picture
yeah you know like I said I was just
looking at the picture you know looking
at the beard thinking hey you know and
then all of a sudden like I started
looking at what this man's looking at in
the paint you know and I'm like
you know it made me wonder and then let
me find the Alcazar here for you
we called the
it's in southern Spain it's now property
of the Spanish government but you know
uh
for 10 Generations it was the residents
of the Castilian Kings you know King
Alfonso and he did the alphan scene
tables uh it's you know that's the other
thing you talk about archeology but not
just that I'm interested in astronomy I
look to the sky you know and but you
know being from Southern Indiana ever
looked at me like I was crazy because I
wasn't drinking beer trying to drive a
big truck you know and
yeah what's that matter you know when
they get out here I don't see much well
they're playing beer drinking but you
know there's a lot of a whole lot of big
truck driving being dumb Hillbillies you
know and like there has to be more to
the world and you know I had a friend of
mine who set out you know four years ago
he left the Chicago Stock Exchange it
was a very successful Commodities broker
and sailed around the world went down to
the Cayman Islands you know bought a
boat told his buddies he took a
Captain's Course to come to find out
it's just a booze cruise you know but
that's the kind of guy he was you know
but you know he was the warrior he was
the one who'd bring the others home you
know and
it's uh
would would it be fair to say that
you're seeking the nature of reality
right now you're seeking the nature of
your expression in it
you know I I don't quit but yeah I would
say that would be a fair you know uh
assessment you know I don't you know I
mean reality is
like I said reality is what you make of
it you know I could be out here you know
like
complaining about all this down here you
know and all that but you know that's
somebody else's you know that's their
reality you know and if that's they're
happy in it you know like I said for 33
years ask a follow-up question okay Ryan
have you spent time
investigating the Seer itself that which
is CE
your Consciousness your awareness have
you investigated that
yeah I feel like that's kind of where
I'm at now you know I'm kind of you know
it's almost like you know hey you know
there's so much there's so many cliches
out there like being woke you know and
like you know people say that you
know and what do you really well you
know I mean I mean that sounds cool to
say and music and stuff and all but I
mean
like I feel like indescribe myself I'm
an empath you know like I can relate to
anybody because I've been in everybody's
shoes you know I've been at the top of
the top you know and I've literally
lived in a you know 10 by 10 climate
control storage unit before you know 100
bucks a month
you know so I can't you know
that's key if there was
one of the things for your questions
that you have for people
recognizing Consciousness or awareness
and being really fundamentally aware of
being aware is instrumental in the
nature yeah you know somebody's going to
tell you they're aware and then turn
around and you know run into that sign
you know I'm gonna have a hard time
believing you know that you're really
aware of your surroundings you know it's
not aware of surroundings it's aware of
awareness itself being aware of
perception itself now at some point now
let me ask you do you feel at some point
becomes a little too you know I mean
because they're
you know death is infinite you know I
mean you can go as deep as you want you
know but at some point we still live in
a world where they're walking by you
know they're standing there how do you
reconcile that
reconcile one
the you know the infinite depth with the
you know I don't want to say shallowness
but you know
there has you know we you can't have a
thousand people existing on a thousand
different planes you know
a society you know will not function in
that manner a successful Society I mean
you have there has to be levels but it
can't you know here here this this would
be
reconciliation comes from the
investigation like what you're doing
right now exactly okay now the
investigative process the more that it
focuses on the external the less quick
it will be the more you'll encounter
suffering the more the investigative
process focuses on the internal focuses
on the actual awareness or the
Consciousness that is present on a
moment-to-moment basis here with you and
here with me and there with Mariah and
each one of these agents okay the more
that we recognize that that awareness or
that you use the word agent there I have
to I could see to me an agent you know
they they that person has an agenda you
know I mean that's you know ancient uh
you can use unit right okay okay so
that's what you meant when you said you
know you know hey I like to call it a
soul you know whether some people have a
soul Okay so now the next thought is to
go from the place of being super aware
of Consciousness or awareness itself to
then recognizing that that awareness of
that Consciousness is shared among the 8
billion units and that's where I'm at
right now you're exactly that's what I'm
trying to get you know I know who I am
now you know it took me 33 34 years to
find it you know now I just need to find
no I guess that were you know that eight
billion units you talk about is in
society I refer to you know how
everything interacts and you know you
know
that's yeah I'm trying to find that
sweet sweet Middle Ground you know and
uh so that next step that you said is
where you're at which is recognizing
that the awareness around the 8 billion
units is shared
getting to that point makes it so that
when you see another unit like here in
Mariah here Ryan here Atlas but these
units don't actually have separate
awareness that the awareness is one
awareness seeing
through Ryan's costume seen through
atlas's costs safety Mirage
but the awareness itself that is seen
through those costumes is the same
shared awareness and then the utility of
it is that then what happens is that I
would never hurt myself
you're exactly right you know it's I
mean and that's where kind of like
seeing these people you know 10 years
ago you know I would have been oh yeah
yeah this and that you know but you know
what after being there you know and just
like you know like you said they're
they're the kind of people that is you
know they're externalizing it it's
taking them a little bit longer you know
to find it you know but you know you
have so much thrown at you today
especially in this day and age of social
you know and you know I've been reading
a lot you know I'm a big fan of science
as you can tell like 90 of what's being
put out there is scientific news there's
nothing more than thoughts or conjecture
you know and
you know as like I was taught away like
going to Catholic grade school that you
know when I got out into the real I
guess you know the the scientific guy
you know there is gravity you know
there's something that's keeping us from
floating away you know it's like and you
know I was taught creation like God
created the world in seven days but the
logical mean you know is like
there's no way One Man created all this
in seven days you know I mean now
the god that is reference that's been
perverted by religion which is what you
mentioned earlier yes that the God is no
different than Consciousness no
different than awareness awareness or
Consciousness that is shared among the 8
billion units that is what is meant in
the spiritual Traditions exactly my God
yes yes you are the Seer you are God God
is consciousness God is awareness we all
are that so it's not separate in John
John 10 30 yes I and my father are what
the Sanskrit tradition means we are that
you are that yeah you know I I believe
you know and then you can go back to you
know the philosophical Plato you know I
think therefore I am you know I mean if
you're not thinking what are you you
know and I mean
[Music]
it's a question you know but that's a
question that everybody has to answer
for themselves and you know not
everyone's going to come up with the
same answer I feel like that's where you
know that Community is finding the
people that have that same answer to the
question you do you know and
living you know at that point you know
instead not having to worry you know
it's like
I think there's one truth
[Music]
I I have to believe there's one truth
because anything that has more than one
version is why you know I mean now it
there's perspective and stuff but that's
just that it's a perspective it's not a
truth or a lie you know I mean and what
people want to put their perspective to
being the truth and then everybody else
who you know disagrees with that you
know either they're Liars they're wrong
you know and you see how we can merge
what we were just talking about where
there's the eight billion units that
have their subjective perspectives and
then that have the one truth of being
conscious or aware which is what we
share so the one truth is the
Consciousness or awareness and then the
subjectivity is the unique experience or
perception and then I think that even
that the subjectivity is coming to that
out because you know I mean totally you
know because I mean I'm sure you might
feel a little differently than what I've
said you know I don't know a whole lot
about how you feel you know but I
you know I feel like you would be
somebody I consider of my try you know a
thoughtful person you know somebody who
likewise you know and that's all you can
ask for you know I mean like I said I've
I've been walking up and down here you
know for a few miles you know and it's
like everybody wants to Buck you know I
mean there's some people just doing
their thing skate and ride you know but
like I mean interaction is what humanity
is you know I mean if you know everyone
wants to live this life on their own you
know or live it in their little box and
uh
can't do it you know and uh it's a
mirroring of that awareness to each
other I don't see a different awareness
when I look at you I see the same
awareness undergoing a mirroring process
right and like I said you know you guys
are obviously out here doing this so you
know you're you know you you have a a
Avenue a you know media to express it in
you know I'm
you know I've come to realize this is
where I'm going to come back to to write
you know and beautiful I mean it's you
know there's certain things but there
are certain things you know I mean
people like you don't need to like
clarify you know like I believe I'm big
on defined you know like people don't
like definition you know but that lead
lends itself to ambiguity you know
there's a difference between freedom and
security you know and there's a
difference between objectivity and
subjectivity you know but people don't
want to recognize that they just want to
you know
ah I don't yo we just talked about that
a moment ago right eight billion units
have the subjective perspectives but the
one objectivity is the awareness or the
source the Consciousness itself okay
Source okay I like that word you know
like what
what source what is your you know I
guess your Source you know because mine
is my you know go back go back go back
as far as you can
science calls the Big Bang
go back as far as you can we all come
from the same source so in in that you
know yes I do believe that you know I
mean there you go so then is the
awareness shared
in that sense yes absolutely now here's
my question though you know because I am
a fan of a strong
how do we know what we know about the
universe because you know like I fully
you know they talk about Pangea 250
million most people can't remember what
they did a year ago so I mean how are
you telling me these scientists have a
concept of 250 million of those you know
like to me if you ask me like the Earth
is you know from Pangea was probably
around 30 000 years ago
okay you already know that you're coming
back here to right into the presence
here because you like The Vibes right
the Good Vibes so very good thing is
Ryan recognize
externalization of perception but
recognize the very Act of perceiving
itself and recognize the act of
proceeding here and there and here
recognize more and more perception
itself and recognize that that itself
that Consciousness that awareness that
that is the nature of reality so that is
that agent is the major reality that we
need this perception this awareness
experiences okay question last question
yeah what is most beautiful nature I
mean you know I mean what time takes to
build you know I mean you can't I mean
like I said I I'm out here from Colorado
you know from Southern Indiana you know
so for 30 years I grew up in nothing but
you know dirt bags and you know flat
land I moved out to the mountains and
you know it was good for me but
it wasn't what I was looking for you
know I mean it's a different kind of
active out there than it is out here you
know and
you know it's just I feel like
everybody's time takes the build nature
yeah it's you know I mean it's you know
it's Dave Matthews you know I mean it's
uh you know like you've talked about you
know NWA but like you know to me like
there's songs I can't No Church in the
Wild you know what's a god to a
non-believer you know and uh
you know like I said music is something
that's helped me get to where I'm at
today and uh Revolution the album of
courage to grow
I mean if you're looking for that you
know
internalization you know listen to that
album you know because that is one thing
that kept that got me out of the
Corporate Drive I mean and here's the
thing I've sold Telecom for at T I've
sold software for Autodesk U-verse yeah
yeah yeah hey
around in that area or maybe that sounds
familiar yeah yeah big larger black guy
you know mountain bike yeah yeah yeah
Malcolm's a real good dude you know but
um you know like I said that's one thing
that I got out you know I mean I'm sure
that taught you a lot about that's how
you can walk up to people like you do me
and you know sales is such a key in that
sense but it'll report fast and not just
that but like when you're you know here
you know we're in neutral ground you
know back then we were walking up to
people's houses you know and uh getting
their credit card info in five minutes
yeah exactly you know it's a five minute
friend deal you know and like so many
people I've worked with doing that you
know oh that's a Croc that's a scam it's
a multi-level marketing uh last time I
checked a Walton hasn't stepped foot in
Walmart probably in 30 years so how is
that any different you know all we're
doing is we're just providing people
with a better service if they choose to
we just
about it that's it and then most of them
had a t on the old stuff anyways you
know so like I said you know I mean
that's that's funny right hey Alice it
was a pleasure I'll be up and down I
might catch up with you again so all
right I love this was a blast you too
man okay see you appreciate it thank you
bye